And, you know, I
went to Mongolia
and we brought together this
team, we started packing up.
There's Fred Hiebert,
my partner in this.
We got to this point
where we pass this gate.
There was a gate
that was guarded
by these
Mongolian soldiers, right.
That essentially have been
stationed there for 800 years.
I'm serious. The descendants of
the Darkhads, you know...
this tribe that had been put in
place by Genghis Khan himself
to defend this region,
the Ikh Khorig.
This zone that you know
he closed off to anybody outside
of the Imperial family.
Marco Polo wrote about
this place, right.
The history of the
Mongols was written by
historians like Rashid Al-Din,
from the 17th century.
He wrote about this place.
They wanted to go here
but they couldn't.
And for the first time,
I am entering into this zone.
I am on that journey.
We take that data, we
had the GPS points now
where the crowd had converged.
We could
mathematically calculate
where everybody had
converged and clustered.
And we started
looking and you can
see where people
had converged.
These little clusters
of tags would result in
you know, us finding things
like this huge Khirigsur, which
had been here for 3,000 years!
We started scanning this region.
This is a magnetometer
and you walk
back and forth in these lines.
And you add up all this data.
And of course the
sheep come after you
every once in a while.
And the result is you
create these maps of
what's under the
sub-surface, right.
There is some metal underneath
this rectangular mound.
We don't really know what
it was but it wasn't--
we don't believe
it was, you know
what we were really
looking for.
So we push north,
we push deeper
into this region of
this Ikh Khorig
towards this mountain, right.
This place that legend has
it Genghis Khan went to
every time he went
to war, right.
He'd go there and
pray to Tengri and say
well, you know,
"Am I okay here".
Then he would go
out and wage war.
We would head out
every single day
up into the upper reaches
of this mountain range
to hit all of the
different peaks
to try to see what
people were tagging.
We'd fly these drones
across this whole region
with cameras on them
to look and see
if we could see things that...
you know, were little
higher resolution
than what we were
seeing from space.
We're moving down off the
side of this mountain and
literally this storm just starts
descending all around us.
You can see this big
rain cloud coming at us.
Among it was lightning,
and thunder, and wind
and it started blowing all
around us at this rate
which was, I mean,
really terrifying.
Cause there's no trees
around you to duck into.
We had to move almost a
mile down off this ridge
down to those trees, just to try
to get down below the tree line
get down into the undercut
but we're so exposed, and
we had these big magnetometers
hanging off of our back.
We ran, we ran and the
wind started blowing.
You know, I mean, it started
gushing around us and
I mean, we couldn't
even hear each other.
And as we were running down
off the side of this mountain
down the south-east
flank of that mountain
what would be the sunny
side of that mountain
what the secret history the
Mongols had described as being
where Genghis Khan
should be buried
all these trees started
falling down around us.
( crashing sounds )
And, you know, it was really...
it was almost like...
the mountain was showing us
its underbelly, it was
showing us a window
into the sub-surface,
you know.
And it would be in the roots
of one of those trees
that my life would
really change.
My geologist turns to me
and shows me this thing
and I'm looking at it, just
in the roots of this tree.
And it's this lion face.
We made a plan, as we
were walking around
we're like literally
walking around across
across this grass and the earth
is crunching underneath me.
I could feel, I could feel like
I was stepping on something.
I could hear it
crunching underneath me
like
( crunching sounds )
And we agreed that it was okay
to just look under the grass
like it was a rug, you know
we'd just stare barely
underneath this.
You know, this thing, we'd
look underneath the grass.
And, we were standing on a roof.
And as you look at these pieces
that are in this sub-surface
it's this part of this temple.
We started finding horse
bones, tons of horse bones.
We sent this data out to
get Radiocarbon dated
and it comes back...
at exactly our
sweet spot, right.
Somewhere between 500
and 800 years old.
Genghis Khan died in 1227,
about 800 years ago.
So, Fred and I, we
started making a plan.
And we started mapping
out this region
with whatever tools
we could find.
We used cameras on our drones
and we created this
3-D photogrammetry mapper
of the surface.
And we started using things
like ground penetrating radar.
This is an 18--
actually an eight-antenna
array radar system.
We're doing a virtual dig.
We're trying to recreate the
unknown, in virtual reality
because we can't
actually go there
and pull up the earth, right.
But, I feel like...
I didn't really even have
to look for this artifact.
I just had to look at what
was happening around me
and realize that the
people around me were
they were telling me that
the history was still alive
the artifact was
in the experience.
Did we find the tomb or
did each individual in us
each individual in this group
find something in themselves?